transhumanism is essentially the
philosophical school of thought that
says that human beings should use
technology to transcend their
limitations that it's perfectly natural
for us to use our tools to overcome our
boundaries to extend our minds to extend
our mind we're using these technological
scaffoldings the philosophers Andy Clark
and David Chalmers talk about technology
as a scaffolding that extends our
thoughts our reach and our vision
reycarts while reminds us 100,000 years
ago in the savannahs of Africa when we
picked up a stick on the floor and use
it to reach a fruit on a really high
tree we've been using our tools to
extend our reach technology is us
technology is our extended phenotype as
Dawkins says technology is our second
skin we're not the only species that
does so you know the termites build
these enormous termite colonies which
are temperature controlled I mean our
cities like the termite colony are
really who we are you know if you're
able to like make that cognitive shift
and trance can transcend what endi Clark
calls the skinbag bias and realize that
we don't end where our skin tissue ends
but that we are tethered through our
technological surroundings and to our
dwellings and that what we design
designs us back because what we design
is us ultimately you start to realize
that technology we are technology making
species the same way a spider is a
spider web making species you know
Tarrance a Kevin Kelly who co-founded
Wired magazine describes technology is
the seventh kingdom of life he calls it
the Technium he says that it's subject
to the same evolutionary forces as
biological evolution you know that's
that's the the craziness here is that
we're finding more and more that our
technological systems are mirroring some
of the most advanced natural systems in
nature you know the internet is wired
like the neurons in our brain which is
wired like computer models of dark
matter in the universe they all share
the same internal filamentous structure
what does this tell us that there is no
distinction between the born and the
made all of it is nature all of it is us
so to be human is to be trans human but
the reason we're at a pivotal point in
history is because now we've
decommissioned natural selection
no this notion that we are now the chief
agents of evolution right Edward o
Wilson reminds us we now get to decide
who we become Freeman Dyson in the near
future a new generation of artists
composing genomes with the fluency that
Blake and Byron wrote versus you know
with biological biotech transformation
we're talking about software that writes
its own hardware life itself the new
canvas for the artist nanotechnology
patterning matter programmable matter
the whole world becomes computable life
itself
programmable upgradeable what does this
say about what it means to be human it
means that what it is to be human is to
transform and transcend we've always
done it we're not the same species we
were a hundred thousand years ago we're
not going to be the same species
tomorrow craig Venter recently said we
got to understand that we are software
driven species change the software
change the species and why shouldn't we